i actually have a friend or an old
friend who killed someone
and he said honestly and this is a
little bit dark but he said it was
awesome huh
right i mean he said it was and this was
a bad person they've been in a fight i
mean you know like um
but yeah he said it was there was
something and i mean this guy's
obviously pretty affected you know he's
probably he's kind of caught up in the
dark arts
if you will you know he's more you know
if you were watching harry potter he's
more like slithering than he is like
gryffindor you know right but he um yeah
he said there was something
well it's not like there's no pleasure
in mayhem and destruction right
right it's just perhaps something that
should be replaced by a better pleasure
a better pleasure and i think that
that's gonna watch it if there's no if
there is no meat to the temptation it
would be irrelevant
the darks the dark places that people go
are very tempting
yeah and it's even more complicated than
that because
naive people aren't better than people
who
are looking at the darkness right and so
you know the naive people think oh well
everyone should be naive in these little
boxes and all protected and you know the
people who pop outside of that and
engage a bit with the darker things they
think well you naive people you're just
naive it's like yeah
naive first cynical second wise third
you want to get through cynicism and
darkness to wisdom as fast as you
possibly can and you should know that
that's a place to go
right just like you were saying a minute
ago it's like you need to have you need
to know that there are places to go from
where you are yeah they're always on
and they have to be real and not naive
you know think well why should i be good
it's like well maybe you shouldn't if
good is just naive
but you know people really good people
aren't naive they're tough as
they're tough as they can possibly be
and they've seen things and then they
decide to
become good it's steadfast i mean you
have to you have to i'm realizing that i
have to daily show up for myself
if i want my life to be what i want it
to be right
it is a battle and not only that but
it's like
you have to um you have to have
some sort of a plan when i used to be a
little bit more aimless i was just like
oh
i want things to be good it wasn't
enough no no because
things don't know how to just be good
this is true
all by left to themselves things go from
bad to worse
things yeah things will go out of town
things like yeah yes as entropy yeah
like leave your house alone for a year
yeah see what happens oh it's way better
it's like no it's not it has black mold
everywhere
right and the vandalism moved in there's
graffiti everywhere and yeah there's
squirrels
on a pentagram like things have gotten
out of hand i think good is
more powerful than evil and i say that
lightly man i studied evil for like 30
years
yeah man you're like yeah you've been in
the dark arts yeah well that in the
clinical practice you know so i've
looked at the darkest things i could
find and some of them i barely recovered
from
and you still believe that and you still
believe that good more
i believe more than more than i did
before i believe that
our capacity to transcend evil is far
more powerful than evil even though
evil is no bloody joke well that gave us
world war ii it gave us the gulag
archipelago and the horrors of the
soviet union
communist china and cambodia and it's
like the horrible tortures that went
along with that the mass slaughter
the malevolence and the lies all of that
it's like yeah man
that's dark the light is brighter than
the dark is dark wow and that's
something man because the dark is
plenty dark the darkness issue it did
surprise me because
like when when i wrote maps of meaning
which as as i said was my first book i
started writing that in 1985 and
i i picked the worst problem i could
think of to solve
the worst thing and it had to do with
what happened in auschwitz there was
something that happened in auschwitz it
was a variety of this problem so
people were packed into cattle cars and
shipped to auschwitz and that was rough
man like they were packed into the
cattle car so if it was winter the
people around the edges froze to death
right they froze
and if it was summer the people in the
middle died because they got too hot
right it was horrible right it was
horrible and then they were taken to
these concentration camps right and then
the concentration camps of course had
the
had the gas chambers yes i've been to
visit
and one of oh yes but yeah i've seen
them right and so one of the things the
guards used to do is they take the
prisoners off the cars and
it's not like they hadn't already been
tortured quite nicely and were already
headed for death and so it's
already pretty much as bad as it could
get but oh no that wasn't bad enough
so one of the tricks the guards used to
play was they'd get the prisoners who
could still more or less move to
carry a sack of wet salt from one side
of the compound to the other it's like
when you think well that's not so bad
it's like yeah it's bad those were
the size of cities this was a major
journey and it was a 100 pound sack of
wet salt and especially when you're
poor you're hurting yeah yeah but then
they would have them carry it back
you see that's the little twist there
it's like well it's one thing
if you're a guard and this and the damn
salt needs to be moved and you're just
the
slave owner whip and the whip but at
least the salt has to be moved
the wall has to be built there's
something in it something something in
it
carry that there and now carry it back
it's like okay so that wasn't the
question i was trying to solve the
question is
what would i have to be like to do that
and enjoy it
right because the people there are
people who did that and they were people
and they enjoyed it
and there were a lot of them right and
there were a lot of them yes and they
weren't so different from you than you
think
wow so that's the thing that i was
trying to figure out i was like what the
hell's at the bottom of that
well that's that was the darkest places
i could find to look
there's this story this is a story of
king arthur and the knights of the round
table so they're off to look for the
holy grail which is the
the container of the redeeming substance
so it's it's value itself it's the
ultimate value
well they don't know where to go look
for the holy it's the it's the cup that
held
christ's blood from the cross or maybe
the cup that he drank at the last year
it was an indiana jones
yeah that's right of course and then the
holy grail is a very very old idea and
it it
stands for the ultimate value where do
you go to look for the ultimate value
well the answer in in the story of king
arthur and the holy grail is all the
knights are around a round table because
they're all equal they all decide to go
off and look
for the round table so they all go look
at the forest and each knight looks and
sees where the forest looks darkest to
him
and that's where he starts it's like yes
that's wisdom
and i learned that also from carl jung
he derived a dictum from alchemy
institution inventor which means that
which you most
need to find will be found where you
least want to look
right but what's so interesting and this
i didn't expect this is that
if you peer into the darkest dark you
find the brightest light
and i never expected that but that's
what happened i thought oh
this is horrible horrible even beyond
what i could comprehend
and but but the light that can overcome
that that exists the light that can
overcome that exists it's
actually real and i think the instinct
that we have
that manifests itself within us as
meaning
which is what you feel for example when
you listen to music that you really love
you feel that sense of intrinsic meaning
that meaning is a guide to the light and
try i don't mean
i mean metaphorically right i mean
religiously but i also mean biologically
right
in reality that sense of meaning is the
guide to the light that overcomes the
darkness
and the darkness is dark it's really
dark
but that means the light is that means
the light has to be that much brighter
and it is
i really believe that i love that and
yeah and you and
just since you've gone there it's like
it's so
um real man it just seems so real when
you say it
for some reason because you've done the
work you've seen
you know you've tried to start at that
darkest spot and then to still say that
that's the thing because if that's not
the story though then there is no story
it's like that has to be the story that
we go
that it ends in posit that it ends that
it goes upward that
otherwise there's no there's nothing
if that's not the story yeah well that's
a very good way of looking at it that's
i think that's so who would ever choose
nothing
it's a it's just such a pointless
there's no it's mephistopheles it's it's
it's satan's it's satan's dictum that
things are so terrible that it would be
better if there was nothing at all
yeah that's rude there's a whole line of
german literature
speculative literature that was that was
that was laid out by
a man named gurtha who wrote a play
called faust about a man who sold his
soul to the devil
for knowledge and mephistopheles
features in faust he's the tempter he's
he's satan himself and his credo is life
is so terrible it would be better if it
was replaced by nothing
it's an apar it's an apocalyptic desire
you're like neil armstrong of the dark
moon you know
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another
and you can watch this one you can watch
this one different options different
choices
some guy just brings you one option not
this guy
two options watch one this one or this
one